Joyce done and her friends didn't
imagine they will be doing this trying
to convince people to vote for a
same-sex marriage in a possible public
vote but people don't seem to care no
one wants to take the leaflets passes by
a totally indifferent that's the
situation we're facing now
[Music]
besides indifference society's also
deeply divided I support LGBT even the
Pope said homosexuality is something
you're born with the legalization of
same-sex marriage will influence the
moral fabric of the family I strongly
disagree
taiwan's LGBT community is disappointed
only a year back is seemed they were on
their way to marriage equality support
had been strong and very visible for
same-sex marriages a landmark ruling by
the highest court gave authorities two
years to pass legislation that would
have strengthened gay rights both
elections around the corner the
government has been reluctant to do so
yo mainly supports same-sex marriage in
Taiwan
she's candid about why the government is
dragging his feet in the matter
regarding the rampa topic on chichi a
Jojo the president doesn't dare pass a
bill in line with the top judge's ruling
because many of her supporters are
strongly opposed to it they worry that
society will be up ended if such a bill
is passed
how about your horrible show where we
couldn't win one
Joyce done and her girlfriend Miho
certainly hopes society sees their point
of view and allows them the same
marriage rights as millions of other
Taiwanese